aquí tenemos un triángulo a bs lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es dar la
definición de mediana ver cómo se
relacionan las medianas de un triángulo
entre sí y ver qué propiedades
interesantes cumplen bueno una mediana
en un triángulo es un segmento o bien lo
puedes pensar como la recta que va de
uno de los vértices al punto medio del
lado opuesto por ejemplo si aquí de
fuera el punto medio es decir un punto
tal que vd es igual a cede entonces a d
sería mediana del triángulo esta de aquí
sería una mediana también podemos trazar
una mediana por b y una por c vamos a
dibujarlas entonces aquí necesitaríamos
el punto medio digamos en un punto tal
que hay fuera igual a ese y esta mediana
vamos a pintarla con azul la mediana b y
finalmente voy a trazar la mediana desde
c la voy a poner en color rosa brillante
entonces ahí tenemos rosa brillante y
vamos a tener que aquí llega al punto
medio
efe de hecho bueno ya hice el dibujo del
dibujo así pero no lo he explicado de
hecho las tres medianas pasan por un
mismo punto eso
no voy a demostrar ahorita pero es algo
especial verdad usualmente tres rectas
no tienen por qué pasar por un mismo
punto en el caso de las medianas si
suceden y a ese punto especial por el
que pasan se le conoce como el centro de
un triángulo después cuando veas un poco
de cosas de física vas a ver que ese es
el centro de masa si el triángulo tiene
una masa uniforme y luego si lanzas ese
triángulo no sé digamos si está hecho de
metal y lo lanzas girando entonces justo
va a girar alrededor del centro aire
pero bueno ahorita ahorita no nos
queremos meter con lanzar triángulos más
bien lo que queremos hacer es estudiar
esto geométricamente y ver una propiedad
bien padre que se cumple y esta
propiedad es la siguiente observa que
con las tres medianas dividimos al
triángulo en seis pequeños triangulitos
bueno pues resulta que esos seis
triangulitos aunque no sean congruentes
este es muy distinto de éste pero aunque
no sean congruentes tienen la misma área
vamos a ver por qué se cumple eso déjame
empezar bueno déjame empezar llamándole
a este punto el punto
así se denota usualmente el centro desde
un triángulo y lo primero que vamos a
hacer es ver que jefe de ig se detiene
en la misma área entonces esta figura la
voy a copiar para acá la voy a girar la
voy a girar para que sea un poco un poco
más cómoda de trabajar por acá voy a
poner g por acá voy a poner g de este
lado estás en de este lado esta vez de
este lado esta vez y finalmente por aquí
está el punto medio de digamos más o
menos por ahí vale es un punto tal que
esto es igual a esto bueno entonces
vamos a ver qué gsd y gvhd tienen la
misma área y para eso para eso lo que
vamos a hacer es ver que tienen las
mismas bases y la misma altura porque
porque la fórmula de área de un
triángulo es un medio de base por altura
entonces si tenemos dos triángulos con
la misma base y la misma altura entonces
tienen tienen la misma área bueno pero
ver que tienen la misma base es súper
fácil verdad porque se desigual la bebé
ya que de ese punto medio este de aquí
es igual a estar acá
además tendríamos que ver que tienen la
misma altura desde eje pero observa osea
en ambos casos para ambos triángulos lo
que hacemos para encontrar la altura es
trazar la perpendicular desde eje
entonces estaré acá es la altura común
para ambos triángulos y por lo tanto los
dos triángulos tienen una altura de la
misma longitud porque básicamente es la
misma altura ahora aquí puede parecer un
poco raro que la altura quede fuera de
este triángulo pero eso sucede en
general con los triángulos obtuso es
verdad con los triángulos o tus ángulos
si este ángulo de aquí es demás es mayor
de 90 grados
entonces al bajar la perpendicular queda
fuera del segmento pero bueno no hay
problema ya tenemos dos triángulos con
la misma base y la misma altura así que
estos dos triángulos tienen la misma
área déjame llamarle a esa área x
entonces tenemos que esta área x de acá
es igual a esta área x de acá bueno
vamos a aplicar este mismo principio
para otras parejas de triángulos ahora
vamos con la ahe y cg aquí es
exactamente la misma idea
es igual a ese y podemos bajar la altura
desde g
ahora esto es una altura común este es
el obús ángulo que hay afuera del eje y
adentro de ese eje pero no importa
porque pues mide lo mismo entonces base
es igual a esta base altura es igual
esta altura por lo tanto tenemos que
estos dos triángulos tienen la misma
área déjame ponerle que tienen una
cierta área y todavía no sabemos que ye
sea igual a x después lo vamos a ver
pero por el momento déjame ponerle nada
más y bueno y finalmente aplicando ese
mismo argumento a este lado tenemos que
efe gv y fg a tienen la misma base
porque f me dio la misma altura
proyectando desde eje y entonces los dos
tienen una misma área digamos zeta ceta
y zeta bueno ya tenemos tres parejas de
triángulos que tienen la misma área pero
nos gustaría ver que los seis triángulos
tienen la misma área bueno pues lo que
vamos a hacer es otra vez aplicar este
principio pero ahora desde un punto de
vista distinto ahora se lo vamos a
aplicar a triángulos más grandotes al
ave
y al cb a estos dos se acaba le bueno
pues vamos a ver qué nos dice en este
caso una vez más tenemos que tienen la
misma base tienen la misma altura
proyectando desde uve verdad cuando
hacemos esto tienen la misma altura
entonces los dos triángulos tienen la
misma área déjame ponerlo aquí el
triángulo a v
el área del triángulo a hebe que es 12 h
12 h tiene la misma área que el área del
triángulo a c y b se ve entonces estos
dos son iguales y el área de ccm es 2 x
más 12 x más pero a partir de estas dos
podemos deducir que 2 z massieu es igual
a 2 x mac os x más podemos restar de
ambos lados y dividir entre 2 y de aquí
concluimos que x es igual a z 1 si
quieres lo pongo como z es igual a x z
es igual a x de esta forma estas áreas
de aquí dice que son zeta pero las
podemos poner como x como x y entonces
ya tenemos cuatro triángulos con la
misma área y además faltaría a ver qué
pasa con estos de iu pero simplemente
tenemos que hacer lo mismo rotado es
decir ahora vamos a verlo desde la
perspectiva de esta base de esta base y
este punto de acá es decir vamos a
comparar los triángulos que estoy
sombreando ahorita el adc
y el a dv
entonces tenemos una vez más que estos
dos triángulos tienen la misma área
tienen esta misma base y la misma altura
proyectando desde a entonces eso nos
dice que 3 x 3 x es igual a 2 x es igual
a 2
x y por lo tanto restando x de ambos
lados 2x es igual a 12 2x es igual a 2 y
por lo tanto x es igual a que x es igual
a ye estalle se llama en realidad x
estalle se llama realidad x y listo
demostramos esta propiedad súper bonita
de los triángulos si tomamos las rectas
que van de un vértice al punto medio del
lado opuesto si tomamos esas tres esas
tres pasan por un mismo punto y dividen
al triángulo en seis triángulos bueno
pues la propiedad súper bonita es que
esos seis triángulos como mostramos aquí
abajo tienen la misma área